this episode is sponsored by Squarespace
go to squarespace.com
microcosmos to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain
[Music]
every time we see diatoms we have to
give it to them they're just simply
stunning they're single-celled and major
producers of the oxygen we breathe but
the real reason we love seeing them is
because of their frustules those silica
shells they construct for themselves to
live in their Architects building
stained glass walls to float in and the
effect is beautiful
but apparently
diatoms are not content to rest on their
ornate Laurels because some don't just
construct a home for themselves they
construct a much larger structure that
houses a whole Gathering of diatoms an
apartment building made of one long tube
yes a tube they're really striking to
look at like pieces of hay or strands of
hair braided together
the tubes we're looking at right now
come from Iceland our master of
microscopes James sent his assistant
Ella there on a microbe hunt collecting
samples from a bunch of different places
but they saved the Marine samples for
last because those organisms tend to be
more delicate to handle
so on this last collecting session James
was on a video call watching as Ella
scanned the dock she was standing on and
along the submerged parts of the dock
James spotted Tufts of brownish stuff
peeking out as the waves broke so he
asked Ella to grab some and bring them
back the next day she arrived at 6am and
crashed on the couch while James
immediately grabbed the samples to take
a look and apparently the entire time he
was saying this is so beautiful the
samples that Ella brought back from the
dock were teeming with diatoms it might
seem surprising that the Waters of
Iceland can bring forth so much life
especially during the cold and dark
winter months but this matches James's
experience with the ponds in Poland he
gathered samples from which often end up
dominated by diatoms during the winter
even as green algae numbers drop
diatoms seem to be fairly Hardy in the
dark one study found that diatoms
survived longer than flagellates in
extended periods of Darkness
the researchers didn't find a specific
reason why they're able to tolerate the
dark for so long but they theorize that
perhaps the diatoms were more
conservative in how they managed energy
Reserves others have also suggested that
their survival might be due to oils
stored in the diatoms which may keep
them better stocked compared to other
organisms
their survival in Winter means that when
spring rolls around
diatoms are often the first groups to
bloom in polar Waters
and perhaps these tube-like structures
are part of their success they're not
found as often in warmer Waters but
things are different when it gets cold
in 1994 a scientist found a whole bunch
of these tubes along the Dutch Coast in
late winter and buy a whole bunch I mean
there were more than 10 billion diatom
cells living in tubes per square meter
these tubular colonies start with one
diatom secreting a threat of mucus from
a pore which it weaves into a tube
living in a mucus tube might not have
the same romantic feel as the diatom
stained glass shells but diatoms don't
have much need for romance as the tube
gets longer and longer the cell
reproduces asexually dividing and
populating the tube with more cells like
it so they can travel through their
shared home and add to it with every
cell a new roommate and construction
worker is added a cell that can
strengthen and add to the tube by
producing more mucus
at times the cells might reproduce
faster than the tube can expand at which
point they might start to create a
little side tunnel their tube is a
colony and they might end up attached to
surfaces like sand particles or a
submerged Icelandic Dock and they're
kind of similar to colonies we've seen
on this channel like volvox and their
spherical gatherings
one thing that's strange though is that
based on what little we know about these
tubes it doesn't seem as if these
diatoms do much to coordinate their
activity this is different from volvox
where various cells take on different
functions and they work together to
create a better life for everyone but
some of these diatoms act like they've
constructed a crowded City street just
to ignore each other a group of
co-workers who don't even say hi to each
other in the hallway they're little
independent entities countless ships
passing in the night and for those
living in narrower tubes there's no
movement at all they're simply stuck in
place next to a family member they don't
acknowledge but there must be a reason
they live together in these tubes
otherwise why bother with the time and
energy it takes to start making a tube
and to keep adding to it the tube might
be a form of protection making the
diatoms too big for microbial predators
to consume but it's probably also a way
to help the diatom's access light
through a few different mechanisms to
start the tubes help lift the diatoms
away from the substrate they might have
sunk to raising them towards any light
that might penetrate the water and as
they float in the water the tubes allow
the diatoms to move with the rhythm of
the Waves Illuminating all sides in the
process at least that's one of the
possibilities for why these diatoms turn
to tubes
but stepping back from the why it's like
we're starting to see more of who
diatoms are they're Builders they may
have never set out to become that but
their approach to the world around them
has been to build to assemble to make
something functional and beautiful even
if the beauty is not the point
foreign thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the Unseen
World that surrounds us and thank you to
Squarespace for sponsoring this episode
Squarespace gives people a powerful and
beautiful online platform from which to
create their website so whether you're
looking to create an online portfolio
start a blog or open an online store
Squarespace can help you out maybe it's
time for you to take your bookstagram to
the next level by starting a whole book
review blog well Squarespace has the
tools you need they make it super simple
to categorize schedule and share your
blog posts and with Squarespace you can
interact with your community of fellow
Book Lovers through threaded comments
and replies and if you decide you want
to start selling custom bookmarks and
book sleeves Squarespace can help you
out there as well Squarespace is already
a powerful e-commerce platform but you
can even go the extra mile and add
third-party extensions to help you
manage inventory streamline bookkeeping
and ship products across the world and
you can do all of this on one easy to
use platform so go to squarespace.com to
sign up for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch go to squarespace.com
microcosmos to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain
the names on the screen are our patreon
patrons these are the people who have
decided to directly support this channel
over at patreon.com journey to micro so
we always want to take this time at the
end of our videos to thank them for
their support if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
Weiss you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and Tick Tock and you can also
find Journey to the microcosmos on Tick
Tock now if you want some micro micro
Cosmos
and if you want to see more from us here
on YouTube there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]
foreign